so listen there's been a lot of
controversy over producer Pat Ford's
middle name that is nothing compared to
the controversy over Rex Tillerson using
a completely fake name to discuss
climate change you can't write this
stuff disturbing in bizarre revelations
about Donald Trump Secretary of State
Russia friend and fossil fuel CEO Rex
Tillerson this is going to sound bizarre
to you but it's been discovered that Rex
Tillerson used a fake name this is just
the best Wayne tracker Wayne tracker is
the fake name to discuss climate change
while he was CEO of Exxon Mobil and as I
told you before Exxon Mobil as an
organization had evidence dating back
decades that their activities on our
planet were terrible for our planet and
they covered them up for as long as they
could and these revelations relate not
to the company but specifically to Rex
Tillerson New York's Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman has now revealed that
Rex Tillerson used an alias email
address while at exxon mobil to send and
receive information related to climate
change and some other matters and again
the name he used his Wayne tracker Wayne
is tiller sins actual middle name okay
so that part we know where it comes from
but tracker reminds me of The Simpsons
episode where homer changes his name to
max power because it just seems to carry
weight Wayne tracker strikes me the same
way I mean it's not Carlos danger but
it's pretty good as the alias goes and
this is actually all related to the
investigation into whether ExxonMobil
misled shareholders in the public about
climate change we have a quote from Alan
Jeffers whose Exxon spokesman saying the
email address Wayne tracker at
exxonmobil com is part of the company's
email system and was put in place for
secure and expedited communications
between select senior company officials
and the former chairman for a broad
range of business related topics ok so
we're to believe that the point of this
email address was for secure and
expedited communications it turns out
that Wayne tracker aka Rex Tillerson
would use that email address to talk
about whether or not certain
representations about climate change
related issues would be made public to
shareholders
not whether an email address is or is
not secure is a separate issue from
whether a person is using their real
name or not and why our communications
expedited when you use an alias the
argument from exxonmobil to answer that
question as well his rectal ursans
regular email was so widely known that
it was just filled up with stuff so he
set up a separate email for expedited
communications but the real issue is
again if there's nothing sinister here
why didn't ExxonMobil discuss disclose
the existence of this email and the
communications it was used for when the
communications were initially subpoenaed
instead of waiting to see if
investigators would find it as usual tat
the action itself is not the most
incriminating thing it's the obvious
attempt to hide obfuscate or distort
that are problematic I certainly don't
think it's incriminating especially
because he wasn't a government official
at the time sure but the strange part
here is that he must been using this
alias so he can argue against climate
science as we know it that humanity is
obviously making an impact on it because
he's going to have to resort to junk
claims that can be easily rebuked and
he's not gonna be able to defend himself
once people call him out on it so he
wants to use an alias to hide his own
identity well that also is the idea
that's sort of like a layer 2 idea which
is if there was the thought that at some
point these communications would be made
public they didn't want either
anti-science claims or other problematic
claims to be directly attached to the
name Rex Tillerson but again my primary
question is if there was nothing to hide
here why did they try to hide it and if
indeed Rex Tillerson is wrapped up in
the conspiracy to prevent investors in
the public from knowing about the damage
that ExxonMobil was doing to the
environment knowingly now the key word
this would be fraud on a large scale and
it sort of sounds like the perfect guy
to be Trump's top diplomat around the
world right there's actually nothing
surprising and finding out this about
Rex Tillerson and then being told this
is
top diplomat it kind of makes perfect
sense and of course you got the
friendship award from Russia so you have
that angle covered and then you also
have the corporate crony capitalist
angle as well so he's checking off every
box that you would expect to be checked
off if you were going to be involved in
one of the most bolter like kleptocratic
administration's that we've seen